studies show that the average doctor's
visit involves 8 to 11 minutes of
doctor-patient time
meanwhile the medical intake interviews
that doctors are taught to give in
medical school should take an average of
two to three hours this is pretty
typical of the system systematically
people are taught to do something in
medical school that centuries of
scholarly and scientific discovery have
shown or sure that I owe them to bring
humanity's knowledge to bear on a case
and systematically industrial processes
are set up to go through the motions of
doing something symbolic of that but
which there is no reason to think will
actually work we have essentially and
the sort of research which has given us
all of our successes in medicine from
the entire history of medicine like
there have been a few kind of decent
cancer successes but there has never
been a penicillin there has never been a
smallpox vaccine there has never been a
vitamin C for scurvy if you look at the
sort of research that to which we
attribute practically all of the
historical successes of science and
especially of medicine we see that there
is virtually no funding for it and
there's virtually no regulatory
framework for doing it legally and then
for publishing it the sort of research
that we have invented in the post-world
War two ERA is a sort of research that
is designed to confirm and the surf that
we are doing research rather than
designed to cure diseases after we do
the research no one reads it anyway and
it's well known that even if there was
no fraud given the standards that we're
doing somewhere around estrin I and I
just published in the most cited paper
in the history of PLoS on public library
of science
something like 80% of our medical
findings 90% of cancer findings 50% of
the best medical findings most
considered highest quality and 25% of
medical consensus would be force in the
absence of any fraud based on the
methodologies and that's not force in
the sense of useless that's force in the
sense of not true in addition there's
the uselessness of statistical rather
than practical significance etc then
there is the as I say phenomena that
generally no one reads the literature
anyway because as bad as the literature
is it's still possible by digging
through it in excruciating depth and
actually thinking hard in an analytic
way doing detective work with a weak
clues that it provides it's possible to
do enormous ly better then you could
realistically expect to do we have
television shows about medical
detectives
dr. Harris who is inspired by Sherlock
Holmes but have you heard of the CSI
effect CSI is a television show about
forensic detectives and he'll and the
CSI effect is the policy of excluding
people who watch CSI from juries because
people who have a reasonable model of
what forensic forensic science is
capable of but don't realize that in
realistic practice in the ordinary
execution of the law this is never done
will frequently acquit based on the
absence of evidence and a standard that
would be considered adequate on
television and the thing is you could
say Oh silly gullible public who expect
things to be done right like they are on
television or you could say silly
corrupt system that expects people to
consider it illegitimate even though
everyone can be shown on television what
the legitimate scientific evidence-based
version of the system would look like we
have the same with dr. Hales what we
have in the real world is not for the
most part in non dramatized
ordinary cases we do not have detectives
investigating crimes in a analytical
scientific
evidence based exploratory men we have
police executing police procedures and
that works reasonably well for
maintaining public order but it's not a
plausibly good way of digging into
mysteries of any sort likewise the
hospitals we have execute procedures
which prevent doctors from actually
having freedom to think and figure
things out
doctors have sort of legal rights to do
so but they're basically afraid to do so
because the insurance companies and
professional opinion and the legal
system or make it dangerous to do so at
all frequently and so what we have is
highly trained people who spend many
years learning how to think in order to
heal people then being put in a system
that is a glorified factory where
they're not actually allowed to think
and to figure out how to heal people but
instead are supposed to execute
procedures that may or may not work but
which are statistically if executed
correctly and no one's checking to see
if they're executed correctly pretty
well-known - assuming the literature is
true
be on average beneficial so that does
have some benefits for public health but
it's not really very well optimized for
public health either because if it was
they would be using checklists and
expert systems and other techniques
which have been known for 40 years or
more to be capable of saving 98 to
225,000 lives a year in the US alone
yeah
as Peter froth now says heard not
extensively a penalty and has a -
Kamandi has presented in his book the
checklist manifesto if you would like
actual medical detective work you can't
buy it from the local hospital and you
can't buy it from the Mayo Clinic but
you can if you want to hire a team of
doctors with what seemed to you like
relevant expertise and a team of
scientists to do consulting work work
with them go to medical libraries talk
to the read that
furs and do-it-yourself most people
don't really have the expertise to do
that
and either the tire hire the doctors and
scientists or to do it themselves and
the price would seem prohibitive to most
people and so I've built a system that
can do it for you and the price is not
prohibitive it's actually comparable to
all sorts of luxuries that middle-class
people have all the time like an extra
bedroom or an extra car but it's also
not cheap it's you know you're paying
for serious intellectual work it costs
similar amounts to what it would cost to
pay for a good law firm to investigate
your case if you weren't serious legal
trouble which is something that
middle-class people would not blink
before doing because people are not in
the habit of seeing
medical services as something that they
need to provide for themselves because
they're in the habit of seeing it as an
entitlement to write they do the
equivalent of going to a public defender
almost all the time so merrimette has
decided to focus more on orphan diseases
where the awareness is higher that these
services are inadequate because the
medical system in orphan disease is is
basically just telling the patients now
we're not going to try to help you
rather than telling people falsely that
it's going to try to help them like it
does with cancer or heart disease or
neurological disorders or whatever
you